hello regeneration I'm Greg Alva here
with Mariah Garcia I have caught her up
oh wait no that's take - mariah Garcia
is a awesome youtuber brand new to the
community
welcome to the land she has a segment on
there called talk about it and she
invited me to come on
she interviewed me for a very extensive
amount of time longer than I was paid
for and then she served me tacos from
the place and I forgot all about the
money and I left and but it was worth it
for the tacos and you got a passion
fruit juice I got a passion fruit juice
which is what I named you know some kind
of sex joke it goes you're speaking of
sex jokes Fifty Shades freed official
trailer mariah has read the first book I
did not ask about that experience don't
worry I won't she has seen the first
movie and she hasn't read the second or
seen the second movie but I caught her
up on everything that went down it took
about 30 seconds and now we're here to
watch the new trailer are you excited
come on as excited as I'm gonna get
didn't care to see the second one you
just don't like like these guys I think
you took my girlfriend girl that's a
friend yeah your lesbian lover stay to
see the first ones I think that's why I
went was just to take her to see here
wave more women doing that than actually
going with her with a guy yeah I don't
know my girlfriend does actually she
likes the sex scenes I think we should
go watch this
oh they're already married
spoiler that's annoying this is my lane
that I get to live with you
[Music]
me before you oh yeah this movies
getting cool
[Music]
I bought it for us I should ask you
first
oh hell no whoa way to forward you may
call me
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
what this is an action movie
Vin Diesel's oh that's a real loss
[Music]
[Music]
what is going on
[Music]
don't miss the climax see Valentine's
Day I know I'm sure should be more than
thrilled when I saw the first 50 shades
hated it but then I saw the second one
which is technically probably a worse
movie but I actually enjoyed it
a lot more because I felt like the movie
was aware that this is kind of silly
because the first one was so serious and
this second one I felt like was kind of
in on the joke a little bit so I get the
impression that this third one will
still keep that going especially would
like the way they're advertising it it'd
look like a soap opera yeah that's what
I mean they're in on a pedophile who
lover did he sleep with real estate that
was that was a no no that was Academy
award-winning actress Kim Basinger okay
but you didn't with the Academy Award
for Fifty Shades I know how fifty Shades
can be there which is kind of upsetting
I don't know why you need to get upset
about it they show you like crazy stuff
on this trailer like guns being drawn
and people are being held up and car
chases
hey but they're always like a split
second in the trailer because that's not
really gonna essentially that's how it
is I think they're just trying to make
it okay for guys to go with their girls
right yeah oh there's gonna be some
action Oh sweetie and sex know what yeah
and there's also barely any sex in the
movies although I gotta say that in the
50 shades darker I thought they're the
sex scenes were actually pretty hot for
a movie the first one not so much but
the second one yes I don't know do you
have any appeal and scene yeah yeah
really you actually want to see it's
just so much now you just have to kind
of see it for your song I mean I don't
know if I'm expecting a storyline but
maybe horse not yeah a few new ways to
spice up your life I don't know
interesting interesting why are you
taking your girlfriend who all be dating
at that time that's true I think girls I
know if some girls not gonna get to this
whole talk about it I feel like some
girls watch porn about it talk about it
with Mariah Garcia on the Mariah garcina
YouTube marsinah I got messed up the
punchline I was in high school when I
read so is it intriguing for that cuz I
was the first bit of literature that
I've read that interests on sex like
that but I felt like the vocabulary was
a very rudimentary level Oh interesting
which means Ella like Elementary like
thank you for explaining that yeah
you're like well no it was so like basic
well what did you like about the story
it's just like what you would take from
a female's mine and just exaggerated it
you're like oh this man who's really
wealthy yeah he's very spontaneous and
like has all this power and he's cute -
he's not balding he's physically mean
and you'd like has a crazy kinky
attraction I don't know yeah yeah I get
what you're saying it's just like
exaggerating everything oh yeah he's
like the perfect man except except it
comes across really abusive in the movie
right yeah which is that I don't agree
with the thing is I don't I don't care
about them getting together I don't care
about their actual romance
what do you care about I should like
show some sexy it seems different
because I know the first one there at
least in the book as well that he has
romance problem like he doesn't date he
doesn't make me leave yeah I think this
is cool to see some character
development
oh yeah he's gotta give them back he's
found Anastasia for some reason she's
the one calms him down would know who
actual explanation as to why I'll be
there I gotta finish it I've come this
far
I
come this far jokes people these are
jokes on the real rejects today glad
you're here so Fifty Shades freed comes
out on Valentine's Day I know I'm buying
my presale ticket I'm gonna buy the
whole theater that day just me by myself
my girlfriend can come on the next day
so you can subscribe oh yeah are you
guys gonna watch it you know you gotta
ask that YouTube question you guys know
I'm gonna definitely go to the theaters
yeah it's a yeah
not super excited yeah yeah it's like I
get what you mean I'm gonna go yeah I
got you that's how what's were on that
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell you know
what else you can do that would make my
life happy is if you go check out our
video where she interviewed me on her
talked about its segment it was a fun
fun interview people a delicious one
because it's caught me and it people a
loop that one for me I appreciate
Instagram and a Twitter her Instagram
she poses in like nun outfits Instagram
breakdancing oh you can breakdance a
little bit well that story's gone now
people keep tuning in her story then
become a patron eject today keep
forgetting to mention that but it's
worth it